It is great to have back with us today. Rob
Larson, who's a professor of economics and
also author of the book,
the political economy of Silicon Valley. Uh,
Rob, great to have you on. Thanks David. Great
to be here. So when I was on the Joe Rogan
program a few months ago, we had this exchange
where he started talking about how of course
a company like Google is a liberal company.
And it was an interesting conversation because
it seemed that what he was talking about was,
you know, does Google have a policy about
anti-trans bullying and that type of thing.
And I pointed out, listen, Google is a company
that is advocating for less regulation, is
advocating for at a financial level against
some of the, uh, antitrust, uh, um, uh, interests
that the people may have and may want to have
exercised through their government. And so
if they, you know, have an internal policy
where you can't miss gender people, that's
not really making them a liberal company.
When you consider the sort of broader circumstances
of where they are in the world of regulation
and not paying taxes and so on and so forth,
what is the right way that we should sort
of think about the political orientation of
these big tech companies that often have a
sort of progressive ish seeming public side.
But behind the scenes are really very similar
to, you know, an oil company or whatever else
the case may be.
Yeah, right on. Well that's, you know, very
true. These companies definitely do affect
a very, you know, woke very pro diversity
sort of public posture. But to me, I think
based on my research there, what right way
to sort of frame this issue is to look at
it from the point of view of what the company
wants and then what like the workforce wants.
And if you sort of dig into it a lot of the
time when people talk about how these companies
are liberal and they're so on the left, it
sounds goofy because these are after all publicly
traded corporations who stock is held by the
wealthier households of our society and big
financial institutions. How could they be
leftists and anti-capitalist? I think a lot
of the confusion is people look at what the
workforce is saying and then impute that to
the company.
Like, well, the company must be liberal then.
But of course, as we've seen just in the last
several months, we've had a couple of fairly
significant labor actions against Google where
the workforce, various components of its enormous
workforce are doing walk-outs and going on
small strikes and doing independent organizing.
And just lately, I mean, I think maybe the
ultimate, uh, rebuttal to claims these companies
are liberal. It's just lately Google has been
retaining the same classic union busting,
you know, anti labor organization, law firms
that Walmart and Microsoft have been hiring
for years. You know, and especially too, when
you look at the interface with public policy
in the face of all these new investigations
that big tech, including Google, are subject
to what they call the tech lash. You know,
so the congressional investigations, the,
uh, FTC and justice department, uh, probes
and the state attorneys general, uh, as well,
Google is now one of the biggest lobbying
firms in Washington and spending many million
a year more than all of its tech peers, more
than Amazon even, uh, on lobbying the government.
And of course they play a big role in election
financing both directly and through their
packs. So to me, what I would just suggest
to folks like mr Rogan is it's really worth
taking a small amount of time to differentiate
between what the labor force is pushing for
and what the company wants. And then yes,
like policies, let's say, you know, for example,
oriented for a richer representative staff
as in like perfect, taking the rights of trans
workers versus like the real money aspect
of the equation, which the firms are most
interested in all the lobbying and maintenance
of their monopoly. Google got the FTC to just
stop investigating, investigating it during
the Obama years. Like that's where these bodies
are varied. One of the, um,
big differences between tech companies and
a lot of other companies is that there's often
some kind of, almost like a fairy tale, a
romanticized story about the origins of the
company. You know, Mark Zuckerberg invented
it in, in his, in his Harvard dorm room, invented
Facebook. Jeff Bezos was in some job he hated
and you know, had the idea to start Amazon
and whatever else. You don't see that with
a lot of other types of companies that many
of us interact with regularly, whether they
be car companies of, you know, airline companies
or whatever the case may be. I'm curious whether
part of that is because a lot of those other
companies have just been around much longer.
So the story of their creation seems less
relevant because it's further away or is there
something more, has there been a concerted
effort to keep the mystique through these
sort of fairy tale origin stories?
Yeah, uh, you know, that's a great question.
I think, yeah, pretty much those are the two
dynamics. If you look at all of our great
blue chip fortune 500 companies, including
your classic old accompany giants, you know,
GM and so on, uh, or Ford, uh, you know, IBM,
they all have this very folksy, yes, small
business. I developed this company in my mom's
basement in the depression sort of origin
mystique. It's true. Uh, these companies are
all much younger. Of course. Uh, you know,
several of them are only, you know, 10, 20
years old. So their origin story is more recent
and therefore more foregrounded. But also,
uh, just because of the information based
nature of these products, there's a little
bit more of a, but how did you get the great
idea for this company? Because since they're
information based, the idea for their platforms
and for their services is kind of more of
the core of the whole business than it is
if you're a manufacturing light bulbs and
stuff.
So it's true. Like there really is that small
business started in a garage mystique. But
of course, as I look at in one of the chapters
of a book, uh, the firms vary of course, but
very typically their origins in terms of their
technology comes straight from the public
sector. So Google again is a classic case.
People talk about, you know, Sarah J and pay
SRJ brand and Larry Page, they had the idea
to start the firm and it's this great idea
and they built all these great businesses
since I was just wanting to remind people,
Google's original web address wasn't google.com
it was google.stanford.edu because they develop
that at, you know, Stanford, uh, you know,
research labs in their, a computer science
program, one of the great publicly funded
research university campuses in the United
States where you've got stable funding and
you are allowed to indulge your intellectual
curiosity and think freely about what would
make a good search engine or what would make
a good, you know, social networking system
in the marketplace.
You're under a near term pressure for profitability
to get your stock price up and keep wall street
happy with you in the academic world. You're
free to take your time. And of course the
internet itself, after all was originally
developed by a DARPA, you know, the Pentagon's
research arm along with the university system.
And in the book I just go through, you know,
Amazon, Facebook, Google and the internet
and the hardware itself, like the stuff in
your smartphone, you know, almost all of that
technology comes from one or another public
sector research institution or at least through
heavy public funding, which again insulates
you from that short term market pressure.
So to me, the story of the origins of these
firms is one of the juiciest phony aspects
about them will. So to stick with that a little
bit. Yeah.
Can you talk a little bit about what sort
of regulatory or financial incentives also
existed that allowed these companies to do
what they did and to grow, uh, as quickly
as they did? I mean, it's certainly at a base
level, people increasingly dependent on the
internet and more and more of day to day society
being run through the internet is a huge boon
to accompany that exists on mobile phones
and on the internet for sure. But in terms
of regulation, tax breaks, etc. What else
was done that allowed these companies to grow
so quickly at the start?
For sure. Well, the very, um, loose regulatory
framework is an important part of this story.
Uh, all through the era when the internet
and internet based services were becoming
more popularized like in the, I'm old enough
to remember in the 90s, uh, when the internet
came to town and you could go to some library
campuses and look up other card catalogs,
uh, like th at that time it was a bipartisan
um, view that what you don't want to do is
regulate the internet or online industries
cause that's going to impose new costs on
them or limit their, you know, their innovation
and their creativity. And for the longest
time, like, well through the Bush years into,
into the Obama years, that was something that
was more or less bipartisan. We don't want
to regulate the net. It's growing. It's giving
us all these fun free services and so on.
Now of course, as these firms have become
so important, and as you say, it's, we're
so reliant on them and we start seeing their
power in elections in our society, in the
way that we do with everything through our
phones. People are a lot more interested in
putting some leashes on their behavior and
on their power. But to me the real issue with
having had such a loose regulatory framework
for so long for big tech is what I talk about
in the first chapter of the book. These are
markets that are subject to what we call network
effects in economics and network effect is
just something that applies to certain markets
where an information based product is at play.
And the big thing there is that, uh, with
those sorts of markets, the service gains
value, the more people use it. So like a telephone,
you know, it's more people get on the phone
network, your telephone gets a little bit
more valuable to you because there's more
and more people you can potentially call.
Well, the same network effects apply to companies
like Facebook. You want to be on the network
that has all your friends on it, not on the
one that has no one on it. And Google search,
even it's more people to do Google searches
day in and day out. There are algorithms keep
learning from that. And the more search searches
that are done, the stronger their algorithm
and search processes become. So the thing
about network effects, is there a strong incentive
that leads to monopolization or maybe having
two or three very dominant firms in a market.
And that is what we see in big tech from Facebook's
and Instagram's, you know, oligopoly to, you
know, Google's mobile search, monopoly to
YouTube. There's a long list, but it's all
these straight economic aspects to it. So
there was a big deal made when Amazon, basically
after being shamed by Bernie Sanders, decided
that they were going to start paying everybody
15 bucks an hour. And the end result, I thought
was great. Of course, it was a calculation
for Amazon that there was going to be a PR
benefit, more than likely that in the long
term would exceed the additional cost to them
of paying the 15 bucks an hour. But let's
ignore that for a second. Let's imagine that
it worked in that an elected official shamed
a company and they made the right decision
when Donald Trump, between being elected and
inaugurated, went to, I believe it was Indiana
or Iowa, Indiana, and announced that he struck
a deal with carrier air conditioner, that
they were going to keep their factory open
in Indiana and what he basically did was just
give him money, right? There was a plan where
carrier decided we're leaving and Trump came
in and said, Hey, here's some money if you
stay.
My criticism at the time was this is not a
scalable economic policy. This is saying,
Hey, I found a company that has already made
a business decision. I'm changing the calculus
by giving them some cash, and of course in
the end that money was used to start automating
away those jobs. Anyway, half of the workforce
still went to Mexico. It was a disaster. There's
not that much of a difference in a sense between
Trump giving money to carrier to get them
to stay and Bernie pressuring one company
to pay 15 bucks an hour. Now, of course the,
the one that Bernie did is working out much
better in terms of his result. It's results,
but my question is about the scalability of
policy when it comes to these things. We can't
really be relying on elected officials to
be making one off deals, can we, I mean, it
seems to me that we need something systemic
to be done about regulation, incentives, job
creation, whatever the case may be.
Oh, absolutely. And I think even like across
the wide spectrum of opinions about big tech,
I think that that is sort of recognized. So
again, whether you're suspicious of a big
tech firm, a more laughed or a more conservative
point of view, I think broadly it's recognized
what you need. Yeah. As a set of stable rules
that are uniform one company to another. Yeah.
And stable across time. You can't just be
piecemeal, threatening or throwing cash at
these firms. But again, what it sort of comes
back to though is the power of these firms,
like most companies couldn't get all of America's
cities to debase themselves and beg for a
second headquarters. But Amazon absolutely
was able to do that. And it was quite a spectacle.
And they ended up splitting the investment
and walking away from New York. And then of
course putting tens of thousands of jobs there
anyway without millions of dollars in cash,
which kind of shows perhaps the lack of necessity
for these huge subsidy and incentive packages.
But hopefully with these new investigations
we have coming down at the national level
and indeed the international level of these
big tech firms. You know, we do have the FTC
and the justice department here and overseas,
like the strongest regulations so far that
any of these firms are subject to is all emanating
from the European union, from privacy to data
storage to the right to be forgotten. It's
interesting and of course I talk about it
in the book a bit, um, cause the difference
in these regulatory conditions, plus it does
end up mattering that all of these big tech
platform companies and their monopolies are
semi monopolies. They are all American. And
the European union is used to being partially
dominated by American firms. You know, from
IBM to Coke. But they're a little more willing
to regulate firms that are out of state. Um,
despite, you know, a real political presence
that those firms have overseas too.
But I think a new rules based approach is
very reasonable, especially one that limits
the power of these firms. Again, we have a
fairly long record now of all of these firms.
Once network effects builds up their market
power from Microsoft all the way to Google
and Facebook, they aren't shy about using
it to crush competitors and destroy rivals.
I mentioned this in the book, there's just
a piece of wall street journal reporting about
Facebook and they didn't seem to be using
this word ironically, but they mentioned that
Facebook has a whole little division in the
company whose job is to monitor startups.
You know, new, small web-based firms that
might potentially compete with Facebook or
one of its other apps like Instagram or messenger.
And they try to buy up that from at a very
early stage when they can buy it for just
a million bucks from some founder in their
garage or crush it or go after it legally
in some other way.
And the way the journal described it was Facebook
is out to disrupt any potential challengers,
which is kind of funny because of course all
these firms talk about is how we're disrupters
and we're breaking up that inefficient old
economy now that they're the economy and the
five biggest companies in the U S are all
these tech platforms now, which is unheard
of. They try to disrupt and you know, put
control over their upstarts and small competitors
too. So I think rules that reign in these
firms power or even go further and putting
the workforce and more in charge or you know,
and in that way potentially partially socializing
the platforms. To me, those are the things
we should look at. Things that address the
firm's market power. No question about that.
We've been
speaking with Rob Larson, who's a professor
of economics of the book is called [inaudible]
tyrants, the political economy of Silicon
Valley. We are linking to the book. Definitely
check it out Rob. Always a pleasure having
you on next day. My pleasure